en france les dirigeants du groupe
d'ehpad orpea convoqué aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement après les révélations
d'un livre enquête ils sont accusés de
graves manquements dans la prise en
charge des résidents et s'expose
désormais à une action collective des
familles en colère pour plus de détails
on a tout de suite retrouvé notre
reporter guilmard aux ici devant le
ministère de la santé
[Musique]
bonjour guillemin alors qu'est ce qu'on
peut attendre de cette audition de la
direction d'orpea aujourd'hui
et bonjour olivier et bien tout
simplement que cette direction vienne
rendre des comptes sur la façon dont le
groupe orpea traite ses patients dans
ces établissements je souhaite que toute
la lumière soit faite sur les faits
signalés a déclaré brigitte bourguignon
alors les faits dont parle la ministre
personnes âgées ce sont ceux rapportés
par victor castanet dans son livre les
fossoyeurs qui met directement en cause
orpea et le fonctionnement de certains
de ces ehpad le journaliste indépendant
il ya décrit un manque de soins
d'hygiène et de prise en charge médicale
des couches et de la nourriture
rationnée du personnel en sous-effectif
tout ceci pour augmenter la rentabilité
de l'entreprise alors le groupe orpea a
formellement nié toutes ces accusations
qu'il a qualifié le site de mensongère
outrageante et préjudiciable et souhaite
je cite à nouveau laver son honneur lors
dans le même temps son directeur général
a été limogé et remplacé par le
président non exécutif du conseil
d'administration d'orpea philippe
charrier qui devient donc le nouveau pdg
du groupe c'est lui qui sera auditionné
entendu ce matin par la ministre à
partir de 9h15 ainsi que le directeur
général frans d'orpea jean-christophe
remercie
ça a fait réagir cette affaire également
guilmain
mais en fait si le problème qui est posé
dans cette affaire c'est qu'il y a
évidemment le cas d'orpea donc est un
cas bien spécifiques d'autant plus
inquiétant si les faits sont avérés que
le groupe a engrangé de larges bénéfices
plus de 100 millions d'euros au premier
semestre 2009 21 cela dit on retrouve de
nombreux exemples de maltraitance dans
d'autres établissements y compris non à
but non lucratif la faute à un manque
chronique de personnel et donc de moyens
publics écouter
depuis dix ans il devrait y avoir en
france lui professionnels pour 10
personnes âgées en établissement et il
devrait y avoir 30 euros de l'heure pour
mieux accompagner les personnes âgées à
domicile il faut aujourd'hui que l'état
se contente de faire ce qu'il a promis
pascal champvert qui avait déclaré
également quelques jours plus tôt à nos
confrères de france info que les
pouvoirs publics je citais est habitué à
sous financer l'aide aux personnes âgées
et que partout à domicile comme en
établissement la france et être
maltraitante avec ses aînés il est vrai
que cela fait des années des décennies
même que les gouvernements successifs
sont bien conscients du problème le plan
celui de la solidarité grand âge du
gouvernement de villepin date déjà de
2006 et il n'a pas rempli ses objectifs
en matière de recrutement de personnel
pas totalement en tout cas leurs
résultats les témoignages s'accumulent
olivier les témoignages de maltraitance
alors si il est vrai que c'est bien
orpea qui est entendu ce matin par
l'exécutif le gouvernement sera
probablement à son tour pressé de rendre
des comptes merci beaucoup guilmain ce
fut pour ces précisions guilmard vous
iran en direct devant le ministère de la
santé à paris